bonjour à tous aujourd'hui dans science
clic les échelles de l'univers l'univers
dans lequel nous vivons présente une
extrême diversité ne serait-ce qu'un
autre échelle il fourmille d'une
multitude d'objets tous différents les
uns des autres
cette diversité s'articule en plusieurs
niveaux de complexité qui s'imbriquent
les uns dans les autres
l'univers dans son ensemble et
potentiellement de dimension infinie
cela dit depuis sa naissance au moment
du big bang la lumière des astres qui
sont trop lointain n'a pas encore eu le
temps de se propager jusqu'à nous tout
ce que l'on peut voir dans l'univers est
donc confiné dans une immense sphère de
près d'1 quadrillions de kilomètres
qu'on appelle notre univers observable à
cette échelle l'univers ressemble à une
grande soupe un peu comme un fluide
composé de filaments de matière noire
sur lesquels viennent se greffer des
regroupements de super amas si l'on
plonge dans un superamas il est lui même
constituée d'une multitude damas plus
petits qui sont eux mêmes formés d'une
foule de galaxies si l'on s'intéresse à
une galaxie en particulier par exemple
la nôtre la voie lactée
celle ci est composée de plusieurs
centaines de milliards des toiles pour
la majeure partie
chacune de ces étoiles est entouré de
multiples planètes d'astéroïdes ou
encore de comètes qui lui devra vite
autour
notre soleil l'une de ses étoiles est
situé en périphérie de la voie lactée
dans une zone qu'on appelle le bras
d'orion
comme pour les autres étoiles orbite
autour de lui une multitude d'objets et
notamment notre propre planète la terre
qui orbite à plus d'une centaine de
millions de kilomètres de l'étoile
lorsqu'on se rapproche de la terre celle
ci possède un satellite naturel la lune
ainsi qu'une myriade de satellites
artificiels envoyés par les humains
depuis le milieu du xxème siècle à sa
surface la terre présente d'importants
relief comme le mont everest qui s'élève
à près de 9 kilomètres au dessus du
niveau de la mer s'enchaînent ensuite
les plus grandes constructions humaines
tours et gratte-ciel qui peuvent
atteindre des centaines de mètres enfin
les plantes les êtres humains ainsi que
la plupart des mammifères mesure environ
quelques mètres c'est notre échelle et
celle des objets que l'on côtoie au
quotidien on l'appelle parfois l'échelle
macroscopique en s'intéressant à des
objets de plus en plus petit on pénètre
alors dans le monde microscopique c'est
l'échelle des cellules et des organismes
vivants les plus petits on trouve
principalement des bactéries qui mesure
quelques millièmes de millimètre et des
virus dont la taille peut atteindre
quelques dizaines de micromètres encore
plus profondément dans la matière
tous les objets sont composés de
molécules qui sont elles mêmes formé
d'atomes un atom consiste en un nuage
d'électrons au centre duquel se trouve
un noyau dont la taille est dit mille
fois plus petit que l'atome dans son
ensemble
le noyau atomique et lui même constituée
de composants plus petits les protons et
les neutrons qui sont eux mêmes formés
de quark on entre alors dans le monde
subatomiques c'est l'échelle des
particules élémentaires
c'est à dire les constituants
fondamentaux à la base de la matière
enfin si l'on plonge encore plus
profondément il est possible d'atteindre
un palier de taille infime de l'ordre du
centième deux millionième de
milliardième de milliardième de
nanomètres à partir duquel les principes
mêmes de distance et de longueur perdent
leur sens c'est ce qu'on appelle
l'échelle de planck de l'univers
observable à l'échelle de planck notre
monde peut être étudiée sous toutes ses
coutures de l'infiniment grand à
l'infiniment petit la façon selon
laquelle les scientifiques vont décrire
l'univers va changer en fonction de
l'échelle qui les intéressent à
l'échelle du cosmos et des grandes
structures
on utilisera plutôt la relativité
générale d'einstein qui voit l'univers
comme un tout l'espace temps déformé par
les objets qu'il contient à notre
échelle on utilisera plutôt la mécanique
classique beaucoup plus simple qui se
base sur les principes du mouvement de
newton et qui possède une large gamme
d'applications concrètes
enfin à l'échelle des atomes et des
particules les plus fondamentales on
utilisera plutôt la mécanique quantique
qui permet de décrire les phénomènes
étranges qui apparaissent à cette
échelle cela dit bien que nos modèles
théoriques soit de plus en plus
perfectionnés les scientifiques sont
encore à la recherche d'une théorie
unique qui permettrait d'unifier toutes
les échelles de l'univers
de le décrire dans son ensemble ainsi
qu'à l'échelle la plus fondamentale et
en particulier d'unifier la gravitation
avec la physique quantique pour conclure
l'univers présente une grande diversité
en termes de distance et de longueur
mais il présente également d'autres
types d'échelle et on peut par exemple
s'intéresser aux différentes échelles de
temps l'âge de l'univers est estimé à
13,8 milliards d'années sur terre il
aura fallu près d'une cinquantaine de
millions d'années pour passer d'un petit
mammifère terrestre à nos baleines
actuelle une vie humaine quant à elle
est de l'ordre de la centaine d'années
pour un être humain il faut environ un
dixième de seconde pour cligner des yeux
le quark bottom qui est une particule
élémentaire instable se désintègre en
moyenne après un millième de
milliardième de seconde le quark top
quant à lui qui est beaucoup plus
instable se désintègre après un temps
ridiculement bref de quelques centièmes
de quadrillions nième de seconde
enfin comme dans le cas des longueurs il
existe un temps infime de quelques
centièmes de ces petites îles ioniennes
de seconde en dessous duquel la notion
même de durée perd tout son sens
c'est ce qu'on appelle le temps de
planck
[Musique]